all right let's do audience questions
for the week there are some good ones
this week remember to send me yours
first question David you've talked about
how good the Trump presidency has been
for progressive media and for the David
Pakman show what would be more
profitable for the your show a Trump
second term or a Bernie presidency so
the answer to this essentially comes
down to why we think the Trump
presidency has been so good for the
David Pakman show and I've said before
by the way I talked with progressive
hosts all the time
we all recognize that the Trump
presidency has coincided with some of
the biggest growth for all of our
respective programs that we've seen I
don't know of any of us I speak for
myself only but I don't know of anyone
who is planning to vote for Trump
because it's been profitable or our of
respective shows so the reason I believe
that the Trump presidency has been so
good for our show is not because of the
opportunity to do cartoonish stories
about the wacky things Trump does
although there have certainly been many
of those opportunities I believe that
the Trump presidency has been good for
independent progressive media because so
many more people have become engaged in
politics than ever before when you
looked at the women's March and how so
many of the people in November December
January 2016-2017 were going out there
on the street and protesting a lot of
those people are people who had never
been politically active before and for
the same reason I believe that that is
what has been so great for programs like
ours that there are more people who care
about what's going on politically there
are more people who understand the
importance of paying attention to what's
going on in the world around you and
hopefully people who are planning to
vote in November right I mean that
that's what's hopefully at the tail end
of it so on that basis of course if
Bernie's the president instead of Trump
there are not going to be constant
stories about how Trump embarrassed
himself yet again in front of a group of
20 leaders around from the world from
world countries and they're not even
talking to him he's not even being
invited to climb it stuff that will
change instantly with Bernie Sanders you
won't have any of that but I do believe
that a Bernie Sanders presidency
would inspire a whole generation of new
activists who now see an opportunity to
really participate and catalyze and be
part of the change that they want to see
to our infrastructure to our core
systems healthcare education the economy
etc that I actually think a Bernie
presidency would also be very very good
for programs that have aligned with
social democracy and many of the ideas
of Bernie Sanders for a decade at this
point in time so you know I sometimes
people will jokingly or have to jokingly
say to me hey aren't you worried if
Trump doesn't get reelected that you
know it's not gonna be good for your
show no I'm not I'm actually not I mean
if if I had to say what would be the
worst business-wise for the show it
would probably be some kind of centrist
Democrat or Republican right like I
think if the president is Mitt Romney I
don't know that it's that good for
independent media particularly after
Donald Trump or a lot of people will say
and feel wow we got out of that really
crazy thing the bad things Mitt Romney
would do just don't even rate compared
to some of the bad things that Donald
Trump did I don't think that would be
particularly good for the show at the
same time some some kind of centrist
left establishment Democrat probably
would also not be great for the show in
that there will be a lot of people kind
of disillusioned and feeling like well
we we got someone that's kind of on our
side but not really but is it really
worth after everything with Trump
getting super active now I don't know
that's not my view but that's my sense
of what the the big picture will be so I
think if Trump's re-elected I think it
will be very good for for the program's
continued growth I think if Bernie
Sanders gets elected I think it'll be
very good for progressive independent
media that have been advocating for the
policies that Bernie would try to put in
place for ten years I think that that
will also be very good and in the end I
don't think about any of this stuff when
I think about who to vote for
I just think about whose policies are
like mine or closest to mine that's who
I go and vote for in the primary and
then when it comes time for the general
I again make the evaluation of the
people that are running who do I think
would be best for the country